Sall Paolantonio part of a great team
with NFL countdown he also does NFL
matchup got a great stocking stuffer for
you the Philly special that Sal wrote
the inside story of how the Philadelphia
Eagles won their first Super Bowl
championship and NFL countdown all three
hours from Philly coming up this weekend
Sal welcome the program how's morale in
Philadelphia super high people are
really excited about this game you come
off back-to-back walk-off wins and that
will get the juices flowing
it's Dallas week the hate will ooze out
of the woodwork about 1:00 a.m. Sunday
morning and continue to flow all the way
into the afternoon what's this game
going to come down to in your opinion
three things dance turnovers stop zekiel
Elliott Eagles got to hold on to the
football
you go back to October Dan the Eagles
turn the ball over three times that
would be number 11 Carson works the
quarterback turns the ball over three
times on the road you're burnt toast
you're done that's a huge problem that
he's had and continues to have I talked
to him about it yesterday got seven lost
fumbles yeah that leads all quarterbacks
who have started 15 games this year so
he knows it's a big problem the team
knows it I don't think they're tough
enough thought of that about it I really
don't I follow this team very closely
you know that I think they got to get
harder with him something's got to give
because he's just not learning to
protect the ball and himself in the
pocket he holds on to a too long he's
got one hand on it instead of two he
needs to evacuate the pocket he doesn't
do it
his QB are outside the pocket his third
best in the NFL there's no reason for
him not to get out of the pocket you've
seen him throw it on the run he's very
accurate super strong arm the fumbles
have to stop fumbles the ball against
the Cowboys on Sunday a he's going to
hear a cascade of boos baby Eagles going
to lose the game
but do you think there's some
trepidation consciously or
subconsciously about getting outside the
pocket with what happened in that Rams
game when he got injured well in that
Rams game he ran for it
yeah well I'm saying is he's got to roll
out I'll lock you know you know and I've
been talking about this all year long on
the matchup show look at what Stefanski
and Kubiak have been doing with Kirk
Cousins in Minnesota
Kirk is not a runner but they do a great
job of rolling him out quote-on-quote
you know come some football jargon you
ready for a damn yep moving the platform
there and that's what you got to do move
the platform not move the pocket you're
moving the platform now platform the
launch point correct who comes up with
these it feels like every year there's a
quarter there's a football term that we
throw out there like setting the edge
the a gap high pointing the sleeve is
the one that drives me nuts do you want
to explain the high point of the
football I like how he's he's great in
space oh really
yeah me and you were great in space I'm
good in space I've never been great in
space and it's a vertical passing game
most passing games need to be vertical I
believe but we just keep adding words
we're like the NFL when it comes to
rules they don't they just keep adding
verbiage to it as if it's gonna make it
any better
oh by the way what did you think when
Jerry Jones's Sun came out and said
we're probably going to get rid of
review of pass interference calls in the
offseason what do you make of that well
you know I was in Scottsdale when they
had the coup d'etat remember the the
competition committee came out at first
and said no go we're not going to do
this and then Sean Payton and John
Harbaugh said no momento we really want
this
we saw what happened in the NFC
Championship game we want it
they went to Goodell and Roger Goodell
implored the competition committee to
take another look at it an al river on
and company and they did and they held
their nose through the process and you
see the result what's the result pass
interference that New York does not want
to overturn now whether that's
pejorative or not there's a term for you
whether that's punitive or not whoa yeah
whether that's just them saying hey you
know what we're gonna we're going to
call it and the coaches are going to
have to like it
or or some kind of arbitrary decision
making that's pretty hardcore
conservative I don't know the answer to
that you're just going to have to give
our River on some truths here and then
try to find out but nothing's being
overturned and the result is that the
coaches didn't win because they're not
getting their way do you think Jason
guards coaching for his job this weekend
Dan I'm gonna punt on that one I'm just
not close enough to the situation to
make up to make a really strong point
about it I think there's a lot of
pressure not on Jason Garrett to do the
following to get his young offensive
coordinator to call running plays if
they run the ball effectively with
Ezekiel Elliott they will win the game I
mean Ezekiel Elliott owns the Eagles
right you know the numbers I'll give him
to you anyway
he's averaging a hundred and fourteen
point eight yards per game against the
Eagles that's the best of any running
back against the Eagles all-time better
than Dorsett better than Emmitt both of
those guys are in the Hall of Fame by
the way yeah so Elliott owns the Eagle
so he ought to touch the ball in the
passing game and the running game thirty
to thirty five times in the football
game if he gets a hundred and fifteen
yards rushing Dallas wins yes short
answer yes I do believe so the Eagles
have got to do something about Elliot in
this game and right now even though
they're ranked third against the rush
that's a misleading stat go back and
look at the last couple of games on film
you know they had problems without kamu
grugier-hill not playing in the game
he's their best sideline to sideline
tackler you look at Nigel Bradham he
always over pursues on outside zone lead
runs which is a cowboy staple I'm giving
you real excel stuff here dad I'm sorry
I apologize but you know if you want to
get into the nuts and bolts and the
schematics of it why have the Cowboys
had success they double-team Cox and
they get to the quote unquote second
level and you look around and Radames
not there he's out of position and he'll
isn't injured now and that's why the
Cowboys have had success it's going to
be up to the Eagles to figure out a way
to really crowd the box now let's give
the obvious point which is this if that
Prescott is hurt limited in any way well
it gets hurt in the game it'll be a
challenge for the Cowboys to run sounds
great to talk to you always have fun
this weekend give our best to Edward ur
and Sunday NFL countdown originates all
three hours from Philadelphia this
weekend and also pick up the book and
paperback now Philly special the inside
story of how the Eagles won their first
Super Bowl championship thank you so
that's our pal Antonio there for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]